hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
is a huge day for google and android
fans alike the new nexus family is
finally official today we're going to be
taking a look at everything you need to
know about the nexus 4 the nexus 7 and
the nexus 10. we'll start with the phone
the nexus 4 and i like to think of the
nexus 4 as basically a successor to the
galaxy nexus it's very similar in terms
of how it looks on the front anyway on
the front you have that curved look you
have the very clean front no branding on
it but on the back it's a little bit
simpler and actually like the back it
has a much more understated camera has a
larger megapixel camera which we'll get
to in a second but overall the hardware
looks similar to the galaxy nexus so i
like to think of it as kind of like a
galaxy nexus 2. on the front the display
is
1280x768 but if you take out the bottom
row of pixels when you're using android
the software buttons you'll find that
the usable area is 1280x720 which is
perfect for watching videos and playing
games at that 16x9 resolution it is an
ips display and it also has gorilla
glass 2 on the front which is sweet we
love gorilla glass and inside is a
qualcomm snapdragon s4 pretty much the
fastest chip out there today which will
power through benchmarks and will make
your phone blazing fast now they sealed
in the battery so on the back you're
able to have a 2100 milliamp hour
battery which is a lot larger than the
galaxy nexus and you also have an 8
megapixel camera and an led flash and
this is all sealed in so there's no
expandable storage but you do obviously
have that it's 9.1 millimeters thin so
it's a lot thinner actually than the
galaxy nexus was and it also has a flat
back so there's less rocking when you
press the sides of the phone there is an
8 and a 16 gigabyte version most of us
are probably gonna go with the 16 gig
version and it also has nfc and a
wireless charging dock which looks
really cool inspired by i guess the palm
wireless charging dock from a while back
but you just basically tap the phone and
leave it there and it'll charge without
any wires you can pick the phone off
whenever you want to there won't be a
verizon version this time around on lte
but that's okay because i'm leaving
verizon anyway after all this crap with
the galaxy note 2 button but it starts
300 for the unlocked version which is an
insanely competitive price google has
the price down really well on this one
and as for the 8 gig version you'll be
able to get the 16 gig version for a
little bit more to give you a bit of
perspective the galaxy s3 note started
about 650
unlocked and the iphone 5 unlocked right
now is about 800 so 300 bucks unlocked
good stuff google if you're on t-mobile
you'll be able to get this guy for 199
on contract so all this is uh really
competitive pricing next up is the nexus
7. we already know the nexus 7 it's a
pretty familiar product but they're
dropping the eight gigabyte version
that's discontinued and you'll be able
to get the 16 gigabyte version now for
199 and you can also get the 32 gig
version which is brand new for 250. if
you want a 300 nexus 7 you can get a 32
gig 3g unlocked hspa plus nexus 7. but
we got to go to my favorite of the bunch
and that is the brand new nexus 10 which
is a 10 inch tablet as you might have
guessed with a
2560
by 1600 display
this 30 inch monitor right here is 2560
by 1600 and that is a really high
resolution it's the pixel density is
over 300 it is higher than the new ipad
3 and ipad 4. it is higher than any
other tablet or any other macbook pro
retina or any other screen that you use
with two hands it is that good of a
display i don't know where samsung found
these or came up with these but i'm
really glad that google and samsung
partner together to put this in the
latest nexus tablet make my money
take all of it
on top of all that the nexus 7 comes in
a 16 gigabyte version for 400 or a 32
gigabyte version for 500
and they have a 9 000 milliamp hour
battery in a really thin package it's
630 grams which is the same weight as a
transformer prime 50 grams less than the
ipad
much thinner
i want it really really soon take my
money google take my money please now
the verge also showed the nexus 10 with
this neat flip case it kind of flips
over the back and that's not in the play
store yet but i'm assuming we'll see
this soon in multiple colors since there
was only a red one shown in the video uh
hopefully we'll see like a black one
graphite one blue all that kind of stuff
but we'll keep an eye out for that and
i'll keep you guys updated but most
importantly all of these new products
are launching with android 4.2 jelly
bean with some notable improvements
we're gonna see photo sphere which
allows you to take not just regular
panorama photos but photos that you can
stitch together from all different types
of angles up down left and right hence
the name photosphere and stitch them all
together into a giant 360 degree
panorama of where you're standing and
that's why it's pretty much the neatest
new feature of any sort of camera
software i've seen out there photosphere
is pretty awesome in android 4.2 there's
also the google now improvements android
4.2 gmail with pinch to zoom finally
there is a quick settings panel in the
notification bar i'll be covering all
this in an upcoming video very very soon
with the just the all improvements of
android 4.2 so if you want to check that
out be sure to subscribe and you'll be
able to see when that comes out very
soon android 4.2 is awesome in its own
right but i gotta hand it to these three
new devices the 32 gig hspa plus nexus 7
the brand new nexus 4 and the nexus 10
2560 by 1600 tablet pretty awesome let
me guys let me know what your favorite
device that was announced today is
obviously there was no event today
because of the hurricane right outside
but uh right now i'm digging the nexus
10 and i'm ready to see it on video
officially from google highlighting all
the new features but again like i said
stay tuned for that android 4.2 video
thank you for subscribing and give a
thumbs up if you're excited to see this
stuff in person and uh thanks for
sticking around for 500 videos on the
mkbhd channel either way thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
you